let's talk about a visit to the United
States by French president Emmanuel
macron who went to Washington DC
yesterday first state dinner took place
last night the entire thing was a gong
show from the get-go and I'm gonna get
to Donald Trump's statement about his to
plus our meeting with McCrone
momentarily but just to give you first a
little bit of the flavor for the endless
string of bizarre pho pause each
outdoing the previous in terms of
Trump's meeting with world leaders
during a photo-op in the White House
Donald Trump at one point claimed to be
wiping dandruff off of the shoulder of
the French president and the funniest
thing if you're watching you'll be able
to hear what Trump says whether you're
listening or watching if you're watching
you'll also be able to observe the look
on Emmanuel macron face when Donald
Trump is doing this and it is it's an
amazing reaction by virtue of non
reaction McCrone sort of stone-faced
with a smile right like a an immovable
smile on his face as Donald Trump claims
to be wiping dandruff off of the French
president suit take a look at this take
a listen to this mr. president they're
all saying what a great relationship we
have
and they're actually correct it's not
fake news finally it's not fake news so
it's a great honor
great honor that you hear but we do have
a very special relationship in fact I'll
get that little piece of dandruff or
little piece we have to make them
perfect he is perfect so it is really it
is really great to be with you and you
are a special friend thank you thank you
thank you again thank you very much mr.
president
yeah interestingly that was the least
cringe-worthy moment of the entire visit
so it only got worse from there and they
did a sort of statement after their
meeting they were sitting across from
each other at a table Mike Pence was
next to draught Trump and Jim mattis and
John Bolton was on Trump side of the
table and everything about it was just
transmitting a very very strange
atmosphere let's go through a few clips
from the meeting
little meeting and it turned out to be a
long meeting and it could have gone on
for another two hours we discussed a lot
of things a lot of problems in the world
a lot of problems that we think can be
solved we've come a long way just the
two of us I think is understanding when
we talked about Iran we talked about
Syria we talked about a lot of subjects
that really are big big hard situations
and we think we have solutions to a
number of them so we're going to
continue that now and then Emanuel and
myself will meet again I think after
this meeting right
aside from trump referring to them going
over a number of big hard situations
that that actually again i that's not
the weirdest part of this what's weird I
think is sort of a couple things number
one there's this attitude from Trump
generally that like he's better than the
crumb right on some level he's just he's
a better he's a better man he's a better
person he's more important than McCrone
but also there's this feeling like it's
all sort of a bother to him like he he's
sort of yeah I'm doing this and we had a
meeting we could have met longer we
talked about trade I set the agenda but
it's all kind of like from a point of
condescension isn't that it's going
through the motions he's talking about
law without saying anything and I kind
of wish I could do that too you're just
like well in the air well and what he
ended up doing is just going very
quickly into bragging about random
random things right so there's no real
indication that he actually saw the
content of the meeting with the French
president is that important because he
immediately jumped into bragging about
unemployment rates in different states
take a look very good numbers are coming
out on our businesses you see the
numbers that are getting released on our
companies and our businesses they're
very strong the economy is is been
really incredible unemployment now is at
the lowest point ever in history in many
many states the states were enumerated
last night late last night that
came out and we've hit the lowest
unemployment numbers in many decades in
some cases and in some cases the lowest
numbers period it was just reiterated
that unemployment for african-american
families it's been the best in history
for Hispanic families the best in
history for women the best in eighteen
years and that's very close to going
much higher than that so it's really
something very special so we're very
happy about that it's like what is he
talking about if you're a manual McCrone
and you're sitting there across from him
what what do you make of the fact that
Trump is just making absolutely no sense
and a lot of the stuff he said wasn't
even true he said we've just gotten the
net we've gotten the numbers from our
companies and everything's great the Dow
crashed five hundred points yesterday
unanticipated bad earnings numbers like
where is Trump getting this stuff and it
just went on like this for a while I
don't know what is going through the
French president's head as this is going
on and then Trump talks about his
conversation with McCrone again this
time saying they talked about trade
which I'm sure they did but it's made
abundantly clear that Trump doesn't know
anything about trade look at this the
president and I working on trade the
trade with France is complicated because
we have the European Union I would
rather deal just with France the union
is very tough for us that they have
trade barriers that are unacceptable our
farmers can't send their product into
the European Union easily as they should
and we accept their product so we have
to make a change and they understand
that and we're negotiating Wilbur and
Steve and everybody we're negotiating
with the European Union
yeah but he's doing a great job and then
trade apparently got Trump into talking
about China where it really got strange
take a look at this last clip is we have
no choice but to be very serious
you know we've put on very substantial
tariffs and that will continue unless we
make a trade deal I think where we've
got a very good chance of making a deal
as you know they've just stated
President Xi a terrific guy in a friend
of mine but he's representing China and
I'm representing in the United States
President Xi made a speech four days ago
where he said that China is going to be
opened up it's not opened up right now
they trade with us we can't trade with
them they did five hundred and four
billion dollars last year and we did one
hundred and twenty billion dollars
that's a tremendous imbalance that we
can't have that yeah the key moment
there was when Trump clarified that he
represents the United States and trade
deals it's actually good to clarify that
often I don't know whose side Trump is
on from what he says so it's good that
he said by the way I do represent the
United States here sort of a verbal
Rorschach test of sorts right he later
talked about North Korea I won't subject
you to that stuff and then finally
Emmanuel macron gets a chance to speak
and I realized in his non-native English
McCrone is more articulate and better
able to communicate in a sort of
reasonable human way than Donald Trump
is and with that thank you all very much
mr. president would you like to say
something Thank You mr. president for
these working with wine together again
before the press conference just to see
it had a very good discussion and indeed
in Syria Iran the origin and some other
very important topics regarding our
security and I think we we have to work
together because we've always worked
together on these issues and it's very
important to preserve the stability of
this region and I think what we want to
what we want to do is in the rest of all
people is precisely to preserve
stability sovereign states without an e
ikemen paradise
so Emmanuel macron putting a final point
on that and I decided to wade into
online comments about this entire thing
and the trumpets are just loving it
right despite the fact that Trump looks
like he just woke up at that table and
all of a sudden said wow there's cameras
here and I should say something Oh Trump
must
playing 4d chess it's just unbelievable
every move he makes are so carefully
crafted and just brilliant in every way
so we're not probably gonna agree with
those folks they also like to when Trump
was being adversarial with McCrone so I
guess they can have it either way
shorting before there was like the
handshake games yeah now there's the
kissing yeah bang I like it all really
we're kissing and grooming each other a
lot in hand holding hands and stuff it
was just every every detail down to the
smallest minutiae bizarre and
unexplainable in so many ways and we'll
see what the eventual diplomatic
repercussions are of this very strange
and bizarre visit send me your thoughts
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman shows on
twitter at david pakman show quick break
back after this today's program is made
possible in part by futur futur is a
social forecasting game where you
compete with other players to predict
the future and it's built on the
principles of what's called a prediction
market a scientifically proven way of
using the wisdom of the crowd to create
more accurate predictions about future
events prediction markets have been
shown to work much better than other
forecasting methods like polling or
expert analysis in many cases and futur
has actually taken the concept and
turned it into a fun easy to use social
game you open up the futur app and
you'll see a whole range of forecasts
covering topics across the board from
politics to sports and everything in
between you can check out my predictions
and follow me to get updates on my
profile which is linked to in the
description if you're watching this on
YouTube the tour is a great tool to find
out more about the world improve your
forecasting ability show off your
prediction skills to friends and even
better when you make predictions on
futur you're helping to create more
accurate forecasts for everybody their
mission of creating better predictions
is great and actually going in there and
seeing how well you can do at predicting
the future can be kind of addicting go
to futur com sign up and start making
forecast it's free and it's available on
both Android and iOS as well as on web
browsers and that's f you t you you are
calm